so yeah buildings are responsible for a
lot of our environmental problems and
particularly climate change carbon
emissions and so forth so I suppose you
could say I'm here doing penance for my
industry which I've been in for upwards
of 35 years now so what I'm going to do
today I have a relatively short
presentation then I have your questions
which are terrific so I was quite
pleased with them because you've given
me great fodder when I'm teaching my own
classes always promise there will be at
least one ranch and I think you've given
me several cues that could provoke good
rants here so that's that's the goal in
every class and then I will just sort of
open it up to Q&A okay so this is a
variation of a presentation I did for
the building enclosure sustainability
symposium be eff I don't know if any of
you heard about that it was at Cal Poly
Pomona and June and it's part of an
international conference series world
sustainable building and a very
interesting series by the way you should
certainly be aware of it they it's in
it's an international cycle develop I is
B which I believe is the international
institute for the sustainable built
environment which is kind of a not very
visible but very important group of
international leaders in the sustainable
built environment ray Cole at University
of British Columbia Nils Larsen who's
some place in eastern Canada Krishna du
Plessis and South Africa and a number of
other folks and they initiated this
conference cycle which consists of a
planning year a year in which there are
regional conferences all over the world
and 2013 is one of the regional
conference cycle years and then the
third year which is the world
sustainable building conference that's
next October in Barcelona so if any of
you are interested that would be a
fabulous conference to participate in at
the symposium in
cal poly pomona this summer there were a
lot of international students so there's
it's a very nice conference in that it's
relatively small I'd say in the maybe
four to six hundred range so it's
neither tiny nor humongous like
greenbuild which is our flagship
conference in the building industry
green building industry so a lot in a
lot of diversity but a lot more players
from academia than we normally see and
especially fresh ideas coming from
students which is really exciting so I
would really encourage you to look into
that some more so I did this paper there
knowing that there was a lot of interest
in education in that audience and
because education is a real passion of
mine as a means of accelerating the
transformation of the built environment
because if we don't know how to do it
differently and better than we won't do
it differently and better and our
industry is very change averse the
building industry so it requires a
little you know prodding nudging pitch
forking to move things along so that's
kind of where this comes from now and I
should say too I focused for the last
about four years for five years on zero
net energy in particular I was very
involved in the development of lead for
homes for the US Green Building Council
I chaired the development of that
program for several years leading up to
its pilot and launch and then helped a
number projects get started in the pilot
nurtured those programs and then I sort
of said okay what's next I'm always kind
of looking for the next big Earl ever
you know how do we how do we move this
industry along give me a cattle prod
right so I thought well climate change
is really in my view arguably the most
pressing crisis facing the building
industry and for
ticular and I felt that zero net energy
which was bubbling up as an area of
interest wasn't getting the interested
it needed and also I knew a lot about it
but I had been studying in this field
for 15 years by then and had 20 more
years behind me in professional practice
to build on and that's not a very
efficient way to provide tools to people
who are interested so I thought maybe I
should write a book so I did wrote a
book called energy free homes for small
planet I apologize I should have brought
a copy to show you but I didn't what was
me that's in my trunk we had time I
suppose I could run and go get it and so
that's been a real focus so the original
title said zero net energy building
education manifesto but really these
principles apply universally across the
field of sustainable building so you
know we're looking at this and what we
mean by sustainable building of course
is not that we know what a sustainable
building looks like you guys read the
reading right so it's really not an
adjective describing the building it's
more I like to think of it Jason
MacLennan who wrote that chapter in the
book thinks of it as a philosophy I
prefer to think of it as navigational
guidance you know this is a compass
direction in which you know we hope to
be heading so that's kind of my view of
sustainable building and again the core
pieces for market transformation are the
same regardless of sort of how you
approach that so my arguments for this
revolve around the fact that our
challenge is in achieving high
performance in buildings actually aren't
technological primarily we tend to see a
lot of emphasis on technology in fact if
anybody goes to green build which is a
couple of weeks hint hence in
Philadelphia you know it's a huge you
know thirty forty thousand people at
this conference
an enormous trade show floor full of
technologies and there is a place for
technologies they can help us achieve
you know more course correction in that
guidance towards sustainable building
whatever that might look like in the
future but there are so many things that
we know how to do now and we don't do
them well or consistently so this is
just one example in a conventional home
we have rules of thumb that govern the
way our building trades and and
contractors size air conditioning
systems so in a standard building that
doesn't have you know any real
particular attention to the quality of
the building enclosure that is its
thermal integrity and we using rules of
thumb we would have for example a
four-ton air conditioner if we do a good
job with a thermal enclosure we can
actually reduce the loads by half if we
install the system properly we can get
twice the performance out of a given
piece of equipment with the net effect
that we could get away with a one-ton
air conditioner instead of a four-ton
and you'll see my little caveat here the
the asterisk note oh right and by the
way we could also have smaller ducts
that are easier to fit within the
pressure and thermal boundaries so
really might even be under one ton oh
right except we have trouble finding
systems that small so that's where the
technology piece comes in but but there
are it is possible we have people who
are sort of rejiggering existing
equipment to get smaller capacity out of
it so why doesn't that happen it's
because we're not doing these things
intelligently it is possible to build
this thermal enclosure it is possible to
do a quality installation of the HVAC
system but we just kind of don't seem to
produce an industry that does that so we
need to educate
another example so occupants it for many
years when I was working on lead for
homes part of my job was to go out and
speak at conferences and meetings and
talk about what the US Green Building
Council was trying to accomplish with
this new rating system for homes and to
find out from these audiences what what
should this program do what should it be
how should it transform the industry and
there were number things that I learned
in the course of going out and and
meeting with people many of whom were
green builders who'd been producing very
green homes for a long time and one of
the things that they would very
predictably say is you know we build the
greenest houses and then people know
that and those people they just they
don't know how to operate those homes so
with hmm okay well I'm not sure we can
operate the homes for the people but we
certainly need to be thinking more
creatively and cleverly about how we
design with the occupant in mind and how
we engage occupants successfully so and
we start to realize this is even more
important and in California in
particular but certainly in nationally
and internationally as we have addressed
energy efficiency in buildings we've
come to understand how to make a more
thermally efficient enclosure you know
how to size equipment smaller and so
forth even if it's not done universally
and done well this is understanding that
is certainly very accessible as we do
those things well we find that the plug
load piece which is the things the
occupants bring into their homes and
that they are in charge of operating
become a more and more dominant piece of
the energy equation so on the left your
left the normal distribution of loads in
a residential pie you see
plug loads are the the yellow wedge at
about seventeen percent these are of
course averages they're going to change
from place to place in a more efficient
enclosure when you reduce the those
loads then you see hmm without doing
anything with plug loads all of a sudden
they're a bigger piece of the problem
that remains to be solved so this also
is not a technological problem this is a
people problem so how do we get people
to do things differently will we can't
do the same thing over and over this is
a fairly well enshrined bit of wisdom
and turns out that education is a big
part of how we tackle problem solving
and you know this is something that's
been implicit in my thinking for a long
time but when I was developing this
presentation I went hunting for some
quotes because I thought did I just make
this up that's the role of education is
to change culture well turns out no I
didn't make it up again this is their
people older and wiser than I who sort
of reinforce this notion and I'm i
really love both of these quotes the
first one of course because it sort of
says exactly what my sort of intuitive
premise was that that is the role of
education but the second one from Jerome
Bruner it was a two-time member actually
as a president Science Advisory
Committee I'm going to read it just
because I love it so much and then we
have auditory as well as visual
absorption education must be not only a
transmission of culture but also a
provider of alternative views of the
world and a strengthener of the will to
explore them isn't that marvelous right
so it's not just the information but
it's there's another way to look at
things and yes we can create change
right so this is the role of Education
maybe you didn't know that's why you're
here but it is so what does that
education need to focus on I've got
three three principles here the first
one is
and this addresses at least one of you
raised this in your questions thank you
very much rant number one coming up okay
costs green building costs more doesn't
it no by the way which one do you
remember which one these waters is your
person which one's mine I don't know
well I'm assume we're not contagious
right okay so mmm it is a very common
belief that higher performance buildings
cost more to build but I think that's
kind of wrongheaded thinking because
let's suppose you're an engineer on a
building project you're a member of a
team you're given a design charge and
you're given a budget so if you meet the
design charge and you meet the budget
does anything costs extra well do you
think it does you're allowed to answer
this is interactive right thank you
that's the right answer no of course it
doesn't and especially if the design
charge says thou shalt be
energy-efficient thou shalt achieve zero
net energy thou shalt reduce carbon
emissions well how could it be extra
then to do those things that's absurd so
what we need to do we thinking instead
is all right as a design team we have
this whole tool kit right in an airplane
you have this cockpit with all these
buttons and levers right well as a
design team you also have all these
buttons and levers you get to push and
pull to make different things happen in
the design and that's exactly what the
design process is all about right is
manipulating all the variables at your
disposal so you do that you play with
all those variables including budget to
come up with the desired performance so
this one I love this navigant highly
respected consulting firm
dissin anybody here mind you but and by
the way peer Public Interest energy
research this hat was for many years a
publicly funded research program through
the state of California I think they've
recently resurrected it and given it a
new name but institutionalized for a
long time so a number of years ago
Pierre funded a study by Navigant in
which Navigant found that there is a 40
to 70 thousand dollar cost premium for
zero net energy homes and I'm thinking
really how can that be if zero net
energy was part of the objective of the
project to choose here in that energy
how can it be extra well I realize after
knowing on this problem repeatedly
because I just I I could not accept this
I was rejecting this whole notion well
it's because they were basically
assuming we're going to take this house
usually a builder a production model
house and we're going to slap stuff on
it to make it zero net energy well okay
sure if it's applique if it's an
afterthought and if you're assuming you
don't get to change anything well sure
it's going to be extra anything is going
to be extra if it's an afterthought but
if you start with your full tool kit and
you get to decide how you're going to
expend your budget then you can
prioritize things like what your goals
and priorities are so that's a problem
there is another way of looking at this
by way I like my way unfortunately I'm
not the only one who thinks this way
Ryan Scott is a builder in Canada who's
been building zero net energy and other
high-performance homes for a very long
time he's saying gee this makes our
houses more available and improves our
position in the market well isn't that a
novel perspective so you know and you
could say oh sure willows your net
energy home that's a higher quality
home you probably aren't going to get
the higher quality product at the same
price right but if it also Nets you a
higher price then it doesn't still
doesn't cost more so there's there's so
many angles on this and some of them
again in my view are kind of wrongheaded
and others a little more right okay so
that was number one cost we need to
recalibrate the second one we need to
refocus where we put our attention and
it has to do with thee is it a people
problem or is it a technology problem so
when clients come to me is another one
of those after X number of years of
doing this type of work and mostly my
clients come to me when they are looking
for some sort of a badge I want LEED
Platinum I want net zero energy I want
to meet Living Building Challenge on the
project and so I work with them and we
try and figure out what are we going to
do with this project to make the
building meet whatever the performance
goals are what would I've realized after
a long time is that there's always some
sort of you know wrinkle some sort of
bump in the road toward achieving those
performance goals and I realized it's
because of an excessive focus on the
product with an insufficient focus on
the process by which the product is
produced so think about this it's easier
for folks in the building industry think
about another industry and then apply
that so suppose your Hyundai and you all
of a sudden wake up one morning you're
the CEO of Hyundai and say you know what
we're going to go out there and we're
going to compete with BMW we're going to
produce high-performance vehicles okay
how would you do that a lot of steps and
I've done this with you know QA and say
so how would you do this and so
constructed this as people feed the
answers you might reverse engineer that
computing product you might research new
materials
methods perhaps go out and find some new
vendors because maybe you're not getting
the high-performance parts that you need
you might actually need to rethink the
way things happen in your factory and in
your purchasing so those are procedural
things redesign the actual production
process is your assembly line all that
it needs to be is everybody doing
exactly the jobs they need to be doing
maybe not so maybe the workers need to
learn something new you might actually
even need new workers new people new
skills new ideas so there are a lot of
building industry parallels here only we
don't tend to think that way and we need
to be thinking that way because when we
start to think in terms of this building
the organizational capacity to produce
the higher performing product strangely
enough it's a lot easier to do that than
if we just leap straight to the end
product right it's like if if Hyundai
said hey let's do BMWs oh goody let's go
pick the new carpet mmm probably not
going to get there real successfully but
strangely enough that's a lot of what we
see in the building industry is let's
pick new carpet or let's pick a new
paint formulation hmmm no actually it's
much deeper more structural and more
systemic than that and we need to
understanding understand how we as
architects engineers consultants energy
experts are part of the process that
creates the product okay integrated
project delivery good afternoon so the
third focus for educationist field I
believe has to be again this is process
oriented the way our industry normally
approaches the creation of buildings is
in a sequential handoff mode so i am the
bridge
and architect I conceive of my fabulous
design which is tends to be very
aesthetically focused I hand it off to a
structural engineer for example and say
now Leslie could you make this stand up
please and Leslie says you okay I'll do
my best she does her best scratching her
head the whole way now why did she do
this oh if only she'd asked me about
this it would have been so much better I
imagine their parallels and other
engineering fields too and in turn it
gets handed off to maybe a mechanical
consultant say okay now could you please
make this comfortable or at least not so
uncomfortable anybody Sue's because
really we don't actually pay that much
attention to comfort in our buildings
which you might infer by how
uncomfortable many buildings are each of
the occupations in turn receives a
pessimist product that they are then
expected to band-aid to the best of
their ability and then hand on to the
next so this doesn't really make the
best use of all of the skills and
knowledge and capabilities on the
project team right if you're somewhere
downstream from the brilliant idea where
it started you're probably wishing that
somebody had talked to you earlier in
the process so that you could actually
impart your knowledge and your insights
and of course when we're working on a
high performance buildings oftentimes
our design teams are really smart
resourceful people and we actually would
benefit tremendously by hearing from
them so at what we have here you guys
have you all had calculus and all that
kind of stuff yes so right this is a fun
thing that takes me back to those nerdy
days when I had calculus and engineering
and why not on the x axis of this graph
we have time on the y-axis we have
common understanding
and you'll see these various benchmarks
as we go along and architect is hired
engineers are hired the general
contractor is hired and eventually the
major trades and then other trades so as
more people are brought in you can see
that the common understanding graph
climbs well when does the common
understanding graph peak answers at the
end is that a really useful time to
achieve common understanding not so much
right so you can think of common
understanding as the area under the
graph right alright so let's look at
another approach an approach called
integrated project delivery we bring
everybody on board pretty early really
really early there earlier the better so
you have your common understanding curve
climb out really quickly achieve a peak
very very early on and look what happens
the area under the graph the overall
common understanding in this project is
dramatically higher than in the
conventional delivery model so here's a
fun thing to think about there are oh
goodie and I have a whiteboard okay so
now you really do have to say stuff
there are a bunch of things besides
common understanding that are improved
in this model can you guess what some of
them are
come on I know it's after lunch
efficiency of labor yep that's a good
one what else communication what yes
yeah communication will just say
communication there are many dimensions
to that but yes that's a very good one
what else it's more time effective for
everyone to be figuring things out
sometime yeah what else collaboration
sorry collaboration is a pit of your
collaboration yes what else I heard
another voice less reworks absolutely
what else
motocross material sorry low across the
material lower nature of us possibly
yeah yes because you can find synergies
earlier and sometimes yeah lower we
already said efficiency of labor so that
can also translate to cost so there are
all kinds of dimensions there what else
there's there some human elements too
it's a collaboration starts to get at it
what happens here when you bring
everybody on board early on ideally you
might depends on whether it's a custom
project or sort of a speculative for
sale project woody just skyrocket itself
hey let's see Comfort usability uh-huh
how about Team Dynamics
it is a sense of community he's a very
good yes peasant you and what might come
from that people are more invested in
the project
better effort Pacific what picture
personally enjoyed success bingo so what
happens okay even in the best of
circumstances with the pinnacle of
collaboration they're always still
hiccups so what wasn't in the case of a
hiccup do you think the dynamics might
change at all project so more
cooperation to solve it yeah more
cooperative problem solving that's a
good see these things flip blue no here
why don't we do this yeah more board
that's always fun
you're having time to think for more
answers here such a long list I love
this and it gets longer every time we do
this let's see red sweatshirt how about
you got some ideas
oh come on try harder how about you
my people cooperate matter what do they
not do as much of fight yeah so less
fighting less finger-pointing
so yeah these are some really really
important outcomes more invested in each
other's success which translates into
greater success for the project and also
so here's here's a fun little bit of
trivia of all the professions that touch
a construction project at one time or
another what role do you think would be
the one of the person who envisioned
these graphs who came up with this idea
about how to represent this
collaborative process ideas who would
that be not the project manager good
guess so who else purple the engineer is
trying to work out each part
individually no possibly guess that it's
not the engineers well go ahead please
no not the supply order ur not that not
the purchasing person who else who might
think of the world in these terms blue
hook the architect who else that's a
good now actually people
okay oh now we're getting closer not the
bank but we are getting closer simmer
not the consumer increase that is the
correct answer so this insight arose
from when things went south right it's
like why didn't they talk to each other
because really that's a problem so we're
not very clever about talking to each
other in this industry and we need to
get a lot better about it now there is a
significant obstacle to this now you
guys how many of you have actually been
out and worked in the construction field
at all anybody know okay so you probably
don't know this yet but one of the
significant obstacles to functioning
this way is what we call the
design-bid-build model so the project
that gets designed we put it out to bid
and then select the Builder and it gets
built right well if we think we need to
put it out to bid we're probably not
getting the input of the Builder during
the design process and we really need
that so one of the challenges that we
have to overcome is how do we get past
the mindset that says oh but I have to
get three bids and to select a little
bid because this is a very dominant
cultural belief that you have to get
three bids and maybe pick the low bid
maybe pick the middle bid but nobody
thinks you are going to pick the high
bid but actually in a high-performance
project the high bid might be the most
accurate one that might represent the
perspective of the person who best
understood the project because it's very
very common practice for projects to be
under bid and then bumped up through
change orders so we want to avoid that
we want to really understand the project
so there's a catch phrase in our
industry its measured
twice cut once my version is design
thrice measure twice cut once let's get
it right during the design it'll never
be perfect never never never it is not
possible for any set of drawings to ever
fully embody every single aspect of the
design of a building however we can get
a lot better about it and especially
when we have all the different inputs at
the table early on in the process so we
did that already so yeah this is I'm not
big on the sports metaphors but Vince
Lombardi got it right here right it's
that they succeed the secret to
achieving success is individual
commitment to a group effort and so that
means we need all those individuals
early so the fastest way to get high
performance whether it's zero net energy
or whatever other pinnacle of
achievement you want in reducing climate
change impacts of buildings is to work
together and to think about things
differently to educate all the players
to produce the better product and you
know there's there's a very pervasive
belief that we have to sacrifice
something green buildings going to cost
more and we're going to have to
sacrifice something well I don't believe
that and this is this project was done
it was a pilot that was sponsored by
Southern California Edison down in
Orange County and strangely enough this
did not cost more to build than a
conventional home of the same size and
the architect who works for by the way k
TG y is a firm that works for many of
the major production builders where
costs constructability budget all those
core business concerns drive the design
and construction they they are very very
business oriented so this is not a lofty
perspective of a pie-in-the-sky
architect who has only luxury clients
building fancy houses this is a feet on
the ground perspective and he says the
ABC green home use the same means and
methods that any of today's home
builders would the simple footprint and
reform keep it affordable with a simple
architecture detailing the design can be
quite aesthetically appealing to the
broadest buyer market so this is
practical it's not pie in the sky it
doesn't have to cost more and it doesn't
have to sacrifice anything in function
aesthetics or marketability that's that
okay so let's see is there easy way to
sort of the slides we can okay this guy
okay sure that makes sense okay great so
see you got a couple ramps all in one
right the random mm-hmm and how did I
think by Sunday night so you know you
put yours in late get return that be
ready to get you out up to and I guess
I'll I'll just start at the top which is
probably alphabetically biased or
something but what the heck so the first
one the question says sustainable
building rather holistic endeavor is the
environmental impact greatest due to the
materials and energetic cost of
construction itself or of the ways in
which we decide to build cities
themselves density course versus suburbs
high-rise versus town homes etc this is
a great question who asked you don't
want to confess anyway doesn't matter
it's a great question because of my
background in training I focus on
primarily on the building but actually I
believe that our land use probably
Trump's ultimately when we think about
the adverse impacts of sprawl and what
that has meant in terms of oh so many
things asphalt coverage in the runoff
and groundwater pollution that goes
without stream saltation transportation
impacts
quality of life issues you know very
interesting fact lead for neighborhood
development was developed it was one of
the more recent lead programs and it was
a unique joint venture between the US
Green Building Council the Congress for
New Urbanism and the natural resources
defense council and so that's already
three very significant players coming
into it and then their first major
funder was the Centers for Disease
Control and the reason that CDC funded
this is because they recognized the
connection between things like obesity
and heart disease and neighborhood
design so there are so many levels of
human impact associated with our actual
development patterns on the land so no
hard and fast answers but I think it's a
huge issue and I think one of the things
one of the big challenges we're going to
face in the 21st century is retrofitting
our cities not just our buildings we
definitely have existing building stock
and several if you asked about that too
but retrofitting our cities and our
suburbs for more sustainable lifestyle
and reduce carbon impacts okay let's see
what is the best method to encourage
sustainable building nationwide
education so here you are graduate from
Stanford and then go teaching or you can
teach in a professional setting I mean
that's basically what I do right it's
like I teach a bit actually as the years
go by I teach more and more mostly to
adult professional practitioners and and
again i really think that it is the way
we think about these problems so which
is a great thing for you to be in this
class and thinking about engineering
because it's all about thinking
creatively about how you solve problems
and so I think learning to look at the
problems
different lens is the best thing you can
do okay how can we decrease it yeah oh
yes yeah how are you making sure that
you're educating the masses like where
are you educating because if you're just
giving lectures to universities that's
kind of like speaking of the choir like
they already know how do you get this
knowledge yeah like not as upper
education class environment no that's a
really good question and it's tricky I
think that it's a problem that am i
throwing him off by moving around or
something yeah right it's a problem that
has to be tackled at all kinds of levels
of society and so you know one of the
things that comes up a lot particularly
in the context of some of the work I'm
very involved in now at the state level
related to zero net energy and the
state's big bold energy goals do they
know about this you guys know about this
so the state of California actually
Governor Schwarzenegger a number of
years ago issued in the executive order
that said basically by decree all new
homes should be zero net energy by 2020
all new commercial buildings should be
zero net energy by 2030 and then there's
more about retrofitting existing
commercial buildings to be your net
energy as well so these are they are
called the big bold goals for very good
reason and one of the things that comes
up a lot in the stakeholder processes
that are being run by the California
Public Utilities Commission is we need
to get to the consumer right every man
and every woman with the message about
the importance of this because we can't
create zero net energy buildings unless
people demand zero net energy buildings
and so there's a little chicken egg
thing going on the real challenge is
that consumer marketing and its really
what it is right if we're promulgating
ideas education
marketing are mmm not exactly the same
but they certainly have a lot in common
in terms of influencing thought patterns
of the public right the the idea of both
is to influence how people think and
what they do and addressing consumers is
hugely expensive so it's a big challenge
and so you know we can look to General
Motors and PepsiCo and organizations
like that they are the ones that have
the dollar power to address the general
public some of our institutions do and
again in California we are seeing more
and more of that a couple of weeks ago I
chaired an event called the net zero
North American leadership summit that
was held down in irvine in conjunction
with the US do a solar decathlon you
guys all know you how to Stanford team
at the Solar Decathlon they rocked
anyway so at the zero net energy summit
one of our speakers with a mayor of
Lancaster California and he has passed a
ruling in his town that says our entire
town is going to be zero net energy by
2020 so that is absolutely amazing and
he basically said to everybody in the
room you guys need to be talking to your
public officials so this is it's not
only is it not a technological problem
it's a political problem cultural and
political right politics is part of our
cultural apparatus so yeah be talking to
public officials a lot of local
communities have climate action plans
and we need to see more energy put
behind those but they're everywhere you
go and everything you do there is an
opportunity to change the way people
think and I think one of the things that
I have seen in my career in green
building is that for some people as
passionate as they might be about
climate change and environmental
problems social change in general
there's a little bit of this is my dirty
little secret going on it's like a
I'm kind of a kind of a social change
kind of hippie crunchy kind of person
and I'm not sure I want to reveal that
to everybody well you got to get over
that right because you don't change
anybody's mind if you don't talk to them
so that's one thing I really want to
encourage everybody if you care about
this just engage people at every
opportunity I'm you don't want to be so
aggressive that you frighten them away
but I think it's really important for
people to be very frank I care about
this this is the direction of my career
and my personal commitment and you know
beans out there as you can because you
will find an audience everywhere you
know whether you're in school out of
school in a professional environment you
know when at gym you guys have kids if
you have kids you talk to people in your
kids schools you know other parents
teachers every social context you have
you have an opportunity to share a
message another rant thank you I do so
enjoy those yes to cream the net zero
energy buildings will homes by 2020 is
that like happening or is it just
something he said or is it going to be
law or yeah very good question yes yes
yes maybe um so in his executive order
well what's happened so i think that was
maybe 2008 2007 2008 and for a couple
years it's sort of like hung out there
and people were like hmm she okay how
are we going to do that right but the
public agencies the Energy Commission
the Public Utilities Commission in the
Air Resources Board you know all
eventually sort of stirred their stumps
and thought okay I guess we might need
to do something about this and so they
all started you know turning internally
the California Energy Commission in acts
legislation that governs energy
performance of buildings the Public
Utilities Commission regulates the
utilities and the utilities have their
hands on some levers related to customer
behaviors and they create education
programs and
incentive programs and things like that
and the ARB has been a little bit more
backseat about it but so the CC and the
CPUC have been the main agencies
addressing this and what's been very
interesting is the dialogue has shifted
from like oh well this isn't a mandate
it's more of an aspirational goals so
they are worried they are clearly
worried about their ability to meet the
goal however I have to say that in the
last year I've seen very encouraging
action in terms of the direction the
codes are going so I don't if you guys
know this but we have every three years
in California we have a code update
cycle and so the portion of the code
that addresses energy performance
buildings is title 24 chapter 6 usually
just referred to as title 24 we also
have Cal green which is title 24 chapter
11 and so what happened is some fairly
early after the executive order people
started looking at the trajectory of our
code changes and said you know if we
just sort of keep on the same
improvement curve that we're on we're
not going to get there and so there's
been some fairly aggressive work to
re-cast you know recreate that equation
differently so that we're seeing much
more aggressive changes to code in the
next couple of cycles so we will have a
new code go into effect January first
and then three years after that so
they're already starting to look at the
2017 code and what that's going to look
like and they are definitely ramping up
to address that and there have been a
couple of very very good studies done
looking at both the technical
feasibility and sort of the
implementation pathway to make that
happen so I'm actually moderately
optimistic that we will get there not
necessarily by 2020 although that would
be wonderful but that we will get there
so there was legislation quite a few
years ago i'm going to say maybe
be 15 ish possibly even 20 s years ago
that set out a statewide mandate for
reduction of solid waste that was a
benign 39 and it required a 75 percent
reduction of solid waste by some year as
benchmark to get some other year and
most communities didn't make it by the
deadline that was given and there were
some fines but eventually most of them
got there so I think this may follow a
similar path way and I'm as i said i
think it's encouraging that we're seeing
the code changes implemented and in a
lot of thought given to to all the other
things that need to be put in place by
the way education being a big part of
that there are six working groups each
working on kind of a different aspect of
the problem sort of messaging and the
technologies and education and i forget
what the other three are but all of that
is happening so how are we doing on time
oh okay good we can run through some
more of these great questions I saw very
far from you know every house being zero
net energy the geese I own so I energy
companies may have not and not seem like
decreases in use of energy but you see
any like pressures presented by the
energy big energy companies against
these efforts to cut down energy use
that's another interesting question you
guys got good ones in California not so
much so we are you guys familiar with
utility rate decoupling this that ever
come up no okay so California I believe
was the forerunner in this there are a
lot of states that have followed suit
now but the common thinking is well
they're selling energy why would they
want you to use less energy right well
we passed legislation in california i
believe about 30 years ago now 30 35
years ago that d couple
old profits from the amount of energy
sold and so instead the profits are
regulated by the California Public
Utilities Commission and so they have to
submit a rate case if they want to sort
of change what they're charging and it's
scrutinized by the state government and
so if energy use goes down their profits
don't necessarily suffer there's an
adjustment made to rates to compensate
for that effect so which is really
pretty interesting and since that was
adopted in California it's been
replicated since in many states there's
I saw a map recently and I was quite
impressed with how many states have
adopted decoupling some of them have
only adopted it for electric or gas not
necessarily both but it's clearly a
trend that is continuing so where we are
seeing some foot dragging is in the move
toward distributed generation so you
guys heard about solar last week so you
probably heard a bit about distributed
generation right so when I have a solar
array on my roof that's like a little
mini power plant and you get more more
of those right that's referred to as
distributed generation well the major
utilities in California for the most
part have a somewhat precautionary
stance about this they're saying oh well
we don't want to really know what the
effect of that is going to be on the
grid right we have electrons going both
ways it like this electrons and wire is
like what's the problem right I you guys
could probably answer that way better
than I can so it's really easy for me to
minimize that that's like absurd however
there are utilities in other parts of
the country who are sort of saying where
is the problem so it's really it's
interesting to see you know when we have
PG&E and Southern California Edison and
and so forth saying well we're really
worried about this and there's
reliability issues and stuff so now I
get it this is their core business and
it's probably appropriate for them to be
cautious because zero net energy means
we are relying
on the grid and they're going to have
you know they have to understand what
kind of supply they're going to have at
what time and what demand you know
through how they're going to match that
up so let's just say they're embracing
that with highly variable enthusiasm
depending on which utility where in the
country so even when like energy use
goes down the utilities profit stays
constant because the rates go up so are
you saying that even if your users use
less energy we're still we're still
going to pay the same amount because our
rates will go up it's just notice huh
but on the other hand we do rely on the
grid so and it's just it's an
interesting problem and you know whether
they will be allowed to have their you
know as we sort of continue down this
path whether they will be allowed to
have their profits remain constant or if
they will be adjusted differently to be
fair based on the service they're
providing mmm I don't know that's way
beyond my crystal ball gazing abilities
but I think you know one of the
challenges is that there's all kinds of
information out there and even builders
who are promoting zero net energy homes
for example you you may see promotional
that says have a zero utility bill it's
like Oh probably not because there are
service charges associated with being
connected to the grid and having the
service provided of you know when your
solar array is doing nothing at night
and you want electricity while guess
where it's coming from it's your utility
company plays a role in that so I'm no
apologist for the utility companies but
I think it's going to be a very
interesting social experiment to sort of
see how all that gets ironed out you
know and if the utilities role
ultimately is perceived to be smaller
and less important and there you there
you know profits go down or if they just
shrink you know and the prophets are the
same proportionately
but they're smaller you know they have a
smaller presence in our social fabric I
don't know I mean that's this is all
going to happen in your life times you
know those of you who are younger it's
gonna be really really interesting to
watch that play out South add a new yeah
how do you define like over a statewide
scale how you define that a building is
zero net energy because like let's say I
move into a house I have all sorts
electronics I'm gonna plug it in three
seconds and it is not going to be zero
to energy by the time I'm done with it
oh yeah like how how do they try to
approach it like the average user has to
be zero net energy why for the building
or how we're different ways people were
tried together right well you're getting
at a really interesting part of the
problem which is that when we design a
building to be zero net energy we're
actually making assumptions about the
the electric loads of the people in that
residence but we don't actually know
right this again this is a place where
crystal ball gazing kind of falls short
and so for example smud Sacramento
Municipal Utility District did a program
a few years ago where they built ten
identical zne homes people moved in they
monitored the homes and they found
differences in energy use by a factor of
three so it's kind of a big deal so
there's one of the big challenges as
being addressed right now is exactly
that question how do we decide or
declare something to be zero net energy
when in fact we don't have monitored
data to say that it really is so and
some of it becomes a semantic question
well do we call it zero net energy ready
or zero net energy capable instead of
zero net energy when we don't really
know so there's a there is that sort of
semantic problem there's the prediction
problem so we're looking at energy
simulations when it comes to code
compliance we will be relying on some
kind
predictive you know simulation tool and
it will be based on some standard set of
assumptions which aren't going to match
necessarily for any particular user fact
they probably won't match exactly for
any user so there will inevitably be the
kind of plus minus is I think the hope
is that there are some who are
net-positive to compensate for those who
will not quite make it to net zero it's
just one of those things yeah just
electronics that is your his problem
then it would seem simple to design a
solar system that you could add to
modular system that you could put a
couple more panels on few more panels on
and and he said or that he would be able
to border his home to be a high
electricity home versus a hello at you
know electricity modeler yeah that's
conceivable a couple of interesting
angles on what you raise one of them is
that if we don't do a really really good
job on the building enclosure we might
actually not have enough roof space for
even an adequate solar system let alone
adding to it so and of course the more
vertical we go the less roof area we
have for the living space enclosed and
we do know that we're in an urbanizing
society and so we are going more
vertical so this is another one of our
challenges that it's actually not so
hard right now for somebody who knows
what they're doing they're paying
attention to get to zero net energy on a
single family detached home but once we
start to go to full you know three and
four stories and above it's a little bit
of a different story now there was
another angle on something you said now
what was it shoot having a range of
options oh yeah so thank you for
triggering that there's the notion of
occupant specific design as opposed to
occupant neutral design and so even if
you're say
buyer and you say oh yeah man I'm the
electronics guy so give me the super
duper model right he may not be the
person who occupies that residence five
years hence or even five months hands
and so we also have that question of
what user are we designing for and sort
of the the fact that a building's
lifespan or in a building's lifespan
that building will likely see numerous
different sets of occupants and or
different occupancy patterns even with
the same set of occupants so you know so
my family well we had an infant we have
different behavior patterns and energy
usage now that we have a teenager so and
I'm sure Leslie experienced the same
thing that things change and so you know
that's that's one of our variables to
consider and what many of our
forerunners in zero net energy homes
right now are custom home buyer builders
you know family X wants a zero net
energy home they have sufficient means
to make that happen in the home is
design for them and their particular
needs which may not look anything like
the needs of the family the future or
even their own needs in a few years so
the question becomes should we only
design for this little narrow window in
time or should we try to design in a
more sort of flexible way I'm personally
a big proponent of the flexible like
could we make the enclosure enough
better so that there is still roof space
left over so and I think that's the
right direction to go
say let's see what else yeah Oh somebody
yeah low-income housing a couple people
did ask about that and I think that
they're a good one too in sustainable
building in general one of the pervasive
myths at is that again it costs more
it's kind of a boutique thing its
high-end and as I said a lot of clients
who are really pursuing very high
performance goals tend to be building
more luxury type residences the
interesting thing though is that it's
actually most achievable high
performance is most achievable at both
ends of the socio-economic spectrum than
it is in the middle and the reason it's
very achievable at the lower end of the
spectrum is because of regulation so
take 20 years ago I would work with
builders affordable housing developers
and builders who say well we'd love to
do that green stuff but if we do that we
won't be able to build one more housing
unit you know that that diverts funds
and that's our primary goal so sorry
we'd love to but no we're going to build
the extra housing unit instead more and
more regulations have come into play
that influence the flow of money to
affordable housing projects because most
of them are subsidized and those
regulations basically say thou shalt
build greener in various ways well when
you've changed the floor for all the
projects and they all have to do it that
part of the conversation goes away and
again this it harkens back to the
political imperative that if we change
that floor of performance for all
buildings the arguments go away about is
it extra how much extra is it even even
though now you're all enlightened and
you can see that argument as specious
which it is but it's even better when
the regulations say sorry that's what
you got to do you know you want to have
a livable planet for your species well
let still with the climate change thing
so talk to your political leaders too
hot okay
thank you thank you for attention
you